[Musik]
das ist der dritte versuch für dieses
video also willkommen zurück mein name
ist vanessa heilt euch gut mir geht es
gut mir geht es fantastisch euch auch
super perfekt ich werde mir heute die
haare braun färben und zwar wollte ich
meine haare also meine natur haarfarbe
raus wachsen lassen das problem ist aber
wenn ich mich noch für einen tag länger
dieser heraus gewachsenen haare
anschauen muss dann werde ich diesen tag
nicht mehr erleben an dem ich meine
eigene natur naja und dann dachte ich
weil ich gestern unterwegs war die
haarfarbe kaufen dachte ich mir dann
machst du dann ein monochrom look und
dann gehe ich in den ersten session
store und was sehe ich da so viele
braune klamotten
deswegen liest man lieber packung
das öl kommt er auch rein
vergessen das öl hinzufügen guckt euch
das nicht ab leute wenn ihr euch die
haare färben gold macht beim friseur
unterstützt das handwerk
ach so kann ich euch noch mal ein
ordentliches vorhersagen so sehr meine
haare bereits vorher aus
dass ich das schon mit dreizehn gemacht
habe ich war damals klein war eigentlich
absolut illegal
wir möchten jetzt zu ende und dann sehen
wir uns immer willkommen bei barneys
beauty teiles ich bin vagni und wir
werden uns heute die haare färben
kennt ihr diese phase mehr video von so
einer jungen frau die sich von ihrer oma
schminken des und die hat diese
handschuhe dabei an
ich finde
so schön wir tun jetzt einfach nicht so
als ob das was verrücktes wäre ich hab
mir schon drei millionen mal vor der
kamera die haare gefärbt wie man es ist
einfach
[Musik]
seit wann sieht haarfarbe so aus ist
auch keine haarfarbe konsistenz jedoch
ich meine strähnen davon 40 jahre also
ich gehe nur bis hier ungefähr ich
dachte ganz ehrlich braune haarfarbe ist
schilliger aber die stehen
und brennt auch ein bisschen ich dachte
das ist nur wenn man haare blondiert
werden wir jetzt die zeit nutzen und ein
paar fragen beantworten die ihr unter
dem garten video gestellt hat und zwar
erstens wie viel hat das ganze gekostet
es hat um die 10.000 euro gekostet also
gärtner produktion equipment deko lampen
alles zusammen um die 10.000 euro das
ist heming geht habe ich bin ehrlich
froh dass es jetzt durch ist das projekt
ist wo hast es hat viel zu lange
gedauert vorbereitung das vor ort sein
machen nachts videos schneiden apropos
schneiden das video habe natürlich nicht
ich selber geschnitten das hat mein
partner timo geschnitten er ist von
beruf kameramann und cutter und hat mir
damit geholfen beim zweiten projekt für
meine eltern war
nein sie drehen
will es mir meine haare
bitte keine director's cut hier kann man
sie nicht ihr achter gartenarbeit den
leuten ein bisschen deine kamera profi
tipps geben sagen hey wie hast du denn
diesen tollen schnitt gemacht zack
snyder
ich bin auch so verwundert es wieder mal
hinter wichtig sind warum wollt ihr
werden es ist so laut
[Musik]
deutschland mit grausen
kraft sagte sie
[Musik]
die pause hat richtig gut getan ich kann
mich nicht daran erinnern wann ich das
letzte mal so aktiv gesagt habe schluss
jetzt ist muss jetzt eine pause her der
algorithmus hat mich komplett dafür
bestraft aber ich habe mir auch ganze
zeit versprochen nicht in diesen
dieses dashboard rhein zu gucken wenn
man in dieses dashboard rein guckt dann
sieht man nämlich wie katastrophal den
kanal gerade läuft und dadurch dass man
keine videos hochlädt läuft es natürlich
immer katastrophaler und alle pfeile
gehen nach unten alle ampeln sind auf
rot die einnahmen waren quasi bei null
was klar ist wenn kein video kommt dann
kommen auch keine einnahmen aber das war
viel das war viel es war damit umzugehen
die kleinsten momente haben meinen sie
und meine panikattacken so getriggert
dass sich halt nicht dauerhaft so
erschöpft gefühlt habe weil ich halt
immer so ein enges gefühl auf der brust
hatte sich immer angefühlt wie suchen ja
dass man keine luft trägt und dann ist
man manchmal so schlecht drauf oder ich
war manchmal so schlecht drauf dass ich
echt da lag und dachte man das leben
macht einfach kein sparen wie jetzt wenn
ich so darüber nachdenke ich war so
schlecht drauf ich will mich nicht
selber mit einer depression
diagnostizieren weil ich bin kein doktor
aber das ist das nächste wie ich das
erklären kann dass ich in einer fetten
depression grimm gesteckt habe und in
den ersten tagen meiner pause meiner
richtigen pause ich mache pause ich
mache gar nichts mehr habe ich erst mal
ein paar tage gebraucht um zu verstehen
dass der alltag den ich mir aufgebaut
habe also youtube videos drehen und und
wie ich gearbeitet habe dass es mich
nicht wundern dass ich dadurch depressiv
wurde
es hat mich ab irgendeinem zeitpunkt
wirklich nicht mehr gewundert wenn man
in so eine situation reinkommt dann
denkt man natürlich erstmal so höhe
warum ich wie konnte das denn jetzt
passieren warum geht es mir dann so
schlecht ich bin doch eigentlich ein
lebens positiver mensch und dann dann
macht's plötzlich so klick weil da habe
ich meinen alltag an schaut und dachte
mir moment mal du bist vielleicht ein
bis dreimal pro woche draußen dann für
eine stunde oder zwei es sei denn du
gehst mal essen oder machst irgendwas
draußen was nicht einkaufen ist du
machst kein sport und wenn dann
vielleicht ein kleines homework auch
zuhause betonung wieder zu hause so
siehst kaum leute corona hat auch dich
auch wenn du weiter arbeiten können das
hat auch dich getroffen und dann hat es
irgendwann einfach klick gemacht und ich
dachte mir ja absolut wundert mich jetzt
nicht mehr warum es mir so schlecht gehe
ich musste halt wirklich erstmal wieder
lernen mir einen alltag aufzubauen der
menschenwürdig ist also habe ich erst
mal mein leben umgekrempelt
ich hab gesagt halt stopp bis hierhin
und nicht weiter und ab so basic sachen
gemacht wie raus gehen braucht wusstet
ihr dass es draußen auch noch ein leben
gibt habe ich mir einen tag auch eine
picknickdecke das ist jetzt wird's
verrückt ich habe mir eine picknickdecke
genommen
und habe mich ein paar gelegen dann bin
ich zum yoga gegangen und dann bin ich
im squash ich hab's kurs angefangen mein
gott es ist so kalt dann bin ich wohl
dann gegangen klettern war auch megageil
damit ging es mir dann plötzlich schon
mal so ein bisschen besser und weil ich
so niemand bin der selbst in seiner
pause so produktiv wie möglich sein
möchte habe ich eine hypnose therapie
angefangen also ich hatte zwei sitzungen
in einer hypnosetherapie hatte ich ja
schon mal wo ich viele sachen lösen
konnte also ich kann über hypnose
therapie noch ein ganzes video machen
wir dass es sehr viel zu erzählen und
viel zu erklären aber es ist nicht so
wie im fernsehen dass man dann irgendwie
keine ahnung völlig frei also dass man
völlig losgelöst und man hat keine
kontrolle mehr das stimmt nicht man ist
darf absolut unter kontrolle und es ist
einfach eine besondere art mit
problemen umzugehen und genau und jetzt
kommen zwei sachen aufeinander wo ich
bis heute immer noch nicht sagen kann
was jetzt wirklich mir noch mehr
geholfen hat
weil mir ging's schon besser aber noch
nicht so wirklich richtig super dann
habe ich mich zum früh mit einem kumpel
getroffen der mir von seiner
klangschalen therapie erzählt also der
war bei jemanden der klangschalen auf
ihnen liegt und dann diese klangschalen
klingeln lässt und durch diese
frequenzen schwingungen whatever das
auch ist
dadurch
heilt der körper die jacqueline ob man
jetzt man glaubt daran und dann fand ich
das irgendwie total coolen dachte mir
ich mache ich bin dahin habe das gemacht
ich habe glaube ich aber auch am
nächsten oder übernächsten tag und jetzt
wird es ganz interessant
aufgehört kaffee zu trinken also koffein
es geht nur ums koffein nicht um kaffee
an sich koffeinfreie kaffee geht auch
und jetzt leute wenn ihr an
angstzuständen leidet und das noch nicht
ausprobiert habt nehmt euch ein stift
und ein blatt papier schreibt auf kein
koffein erstmals test ich habe ein video
gesehen dass verlinke ich euch in der
infobox über kaffee und anxiety und ob
man dadurch dicker will aber mich hat
nur interessiert wegen also der punkt
mit dem seite mit den angstzuständen und
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere dann war
da eine studie wo
fünf von sechs patienten ihre
medikamente gegen angststörungen
absetzen konnten nachdem sie koffein
abgesetzt hatten und dann habe ich den
kaffee abgesetzt
23 tage später ist mir immer aufgefallen
moment mal mir geht's schon seit paar
tagen viel besser aber
aber so richtig viel besser so dass ich
da stand und irgendwie richtig glücklich
plötzlich war und das ist jetzt meine
große frage gibt es nur am café bar café
ein bösewicht nummer 1 würde passen weil
ich nicht viel konsumiere außer kaffee
und halt auf unser alkohol also sandro
moda lag es an der klangschalen therapie
hat der da mit seinen klang schein
irgendwas in mir freude
ruckelt was sich gelöst hat ich vermute
das ist die kombination aus beidem ich
habe aber auch instagram schon was davon
erzählt und da haben wir leute auch
geschrieben dass sie auch kein kaffee
mehr trinken seit sie angststörungen
hatten und es dann wieder besser wurde
ich hätte niemals gedacht ist ok in so
eine negative wirkung auf mich haben
kann und ich bin jetzt seit vier wochen
koffeinfrei und mir geht's wirklich
blenden ich habe keinen einzigen
rückfall gehabt ich weiß nicht ich habe
das gefühl dass mein körper sich gerade
komplett wieder regeneriert ich bin
natürlich mittags manchmal richtig müde
aber dann lege ich mich für eine für 20
minuten kurz hin und mach kurz die augen
zu oder guck mal dass ich besser in der
nacht schlaf und ich so spät schlafen
mail oder sonst was aber putsch meinen
körper nicht so künstlich auf ich finde
das image vom café sitzt sollte jetzt
sowieso mal so ein bisschen wieder das
wird viel zu sehr in den himmel gelobt
und so getan als ob das das geilste auf
der welt wäre bei gilmore girls bei emma
chamberlain bei überall montreux ist
mein körper sonst habe ich schlechte
laune das ist doch chance brauche ich
erstmal mein ruin sonst habe ich
schlechte laune ich weiß es an pocken
linien und ich bin dafür dass wir einen
guten früchtetee oder schön kräutertee
dass heute der nächste café werden sind
ich wollte eigentlich nie mein bauen ein
paar stunden später aber dieses team ist
durch oder wir benutzen das nicht mehr
okay dann sag ich das jetzt noch
einfacher ist ein bisschen netz zeit
vergangen guckt jetzt auch nicht auf
meine haare ihr wollt das ergebnis ja
gleich sehen heute die ironie dieser
ganzen geschichte gehören die aber
ungefähr 200 euro gespart indem ich
meine haare selbst gefärbt habe und habe
einen teppich für ungefähr 200 euro
versaut
perfekt
bin so happy
auch wenn es nicht ganz so gut aussehen
wird aber wenigstens ich habe das gefühl
ich wieder so ein bisschen wie ich aus
vielleicht können einige von euch das
nicht verstehen und sagen jetzt ja
kommen das war doch nur eine haarfarbe
aber es war halt so ein großer teil
irgendwie und wenn man sich halt ständig
im spiegel sieht und irgendwie
unzufrieden ist oder was sieht was man
ja was nicht sich anfühlt wie man selbst
ist schon schwer auch wenn es größere
probleme auf der welt gibt trotzdem ist
es schwer etwas einfach schon wieder ein
bisschen zeit vergangen die farbe ist
jetzt halt eingewirkt und ein paar
minuten später müssen wir jetzt
auswaschen kommt mal ein punkt machen
[Musik]
ich fühle mich wie so ein agent für
seine mission seine haare färben ist das
so richtig gut danach aussieht obwohl
sind selber gemacht in der badewanne ist
ich habe kochen habe ich habe braune
haare
tja
das film sound ich wollte sagen ich habe
jetzt einfach ein braunes hemd angezogen
das ist eigentlich nicht mein look einen
richtigen glück muss ich morgen anziehen
weil es doch einfach zu spät ist um sich
jetzt cool zu sein
es ist wie immer ein ergebnis was okay
ist also ich habe ein paar streifen im
haar ich glaube aber das finale ergebnis
sieht man erst morgen im tageslicht und
so deswegen machen wir morgen weiter für
euch ist das jetzt
und morgen es ist acht uhr ich habe
heute ein interview und deswegen muss
ich
bloß aussehen koffeinfreie kaffee am
morgen vertreibt kummer und sorgen aber
mach dich nicht mache wir müssen mein
badezimmer ich hab gerade überlegt ob
ich sie machen möchten ein ich möchte
dass im badezimmer machen mit make-up
schwimmen
make up
[Musik]
zum glück gibt es ja genug braune
farbtöne in lidschatten paletten hier
sind wirklich 50 james brown
dann natürlich unten auch
das gefühl maskenbildner haben wir schon
oft diesen look geschminkt
sind krank sehen meine augen das haus
ohne abstützen
[Musik]
excuse me ja leute und das ist mein ganz
einfacher morgenlob meine morgen routine
die könnte ich bin ein anderer mensch ok
ich vergleich mal ganz kurz mit meinem
intro
[Musik]
vielleicht ist für euch gar nicht so ein
großer effekt oder so ein großes
umstyling aber ich finde es
wenn ihr den spiegel gucke fühle mich
wie eine ganz neue person eine neue alte
person aber so
ich erinnere mich noch an sieht dann
zeige ich euch jetzt den ganzen block
und ich hoffe dass wege gefallen
[Musik]